il ne faut pas avoir la main fort élevé
pour comprendre que tous nos plaisirs ne
sont que vanité entre nous et le ciel
d'enfer ou le néant
il n'y a donc que la vue est la chose au
monde la plus fragile à ma politique
c'est par un jeu de basse pour l'acaa
sourire ça t'arrange parce que tu es
l'extérieur ou vrai combat monde a tort
j'ai des convictions la peinture la
révolution je parle d'un artiste l'art
c'est la solitude c'est un choix
l'espagne
j'ai actualisé les habits neufs du
président mao il dit la vérité sur le
massacre de leurs émotions culturelle
des acquis de la révolution culturelle
font peur aux impérialistes américains
et soviétiques tu es jeune tu devrais
faire attention à tes lectures ce milieu
c'est être là voilà
m
qui
dans le contexte actuel le militantisme
ne mène à rien le moment de l'action est
venu devant être les nouveaux résistants
ils ont des corrections pour jusqu'au
bout et toi tu fais mieux que si ça
tourne mal jusque quoi problème c'est
pas de savoir ce que tu risque c'est de
savoir si tu décides est cohérent avec
toi même tu as beaucoup de chance en
cours je sais ce que tu seras plus tard
tendre stoxx a raison tuyaux présent
j'ai peur de passer à côté de ma
jeunesse